good evening we'll have more on those
stories in just a moment but first here
at six within the last
hour a judge has ruled that the state's
unemployment department
is in contempt of following a court
order thanks for joining us i'm denise
valdez good evening i'm brian loftis
that order was to pay
certain unemployment claimants in july
joe mohler has been closely following
this lawsuit he's live with what
happened in today's hearing
joe
yeah well this virtual court hearing
went on throughout the entire day and it
wrapped up just shortly after five now
this is from regards to
a certain amount of pua claims that had
started
the payments started and then they
stopped for one reason or another
well the court ordered dieter to correct
payments for thousands but today the
judge said they
did not follow that order we heard from
a number of witnesses including dieter
employees and three claimants who had
their payments stopped
a dieter employee even went over those
claims and even tried to explain why
they were stopped now the judge thinks
there is a certain group of people that
needs to be paid now the court imposed a
one thousand dollar fine and then issued
yet another court order demanding the
state to pay those people no later than
three weeks from today
i am doubling down on the court's prior
order of mandate
i'm directing the state today
to pay those people that i just
identified
no later than three weeks from today
that being and not lost on the court
what day that is
december 24th
now judge barry breslow did say the
timeline set in the summer was not long
enough during the hearing we heard from
a once retired employee who was brought
back recently he said possibly the only
way for dieter to meet that previous
court order was to initiate
a blanket approval of claims again these
payments are for certain amount of pua
claimants
who had payments stopped and then
started for one reason or another those
are supposed to be corrected within the
next three weeks the next court hearing
is set for december 31st
reporting live joe mohler 8 news now